this year for the first time the Academy
is giving an award for the best
achievement and costume design it would
be foolish to elaborate on the
importance of costume to a picture we
all know how very much it helps
generally of course it's more in the
province of actresses and actors with
the exception of period pieces we men
are very often given that show up Monday
in a blue suit we change and so it is
fitting that an actress will present the
award for costume design this young miss
is one who started among us and became a
star at a time when she wouldn't have
been allowed to stay up this late she
has since matured ladies and gentlemen
Miss Elizabeth Taylor
for the best achievement in costume
design of a black-and-white production
bs daughter metro-goldwyn-mayer costumes
by Irene Hamlet J Arthur rank Two Cities
film universal international British
costumes by Roger capers Roger K first
or Hamlet junior rank two city film
universe
you
mr. William Gordon accepted the award
for the winner for the best achievement
in costume design of a color production
the Emperor Walt's paramount costumes by
Edith Head and Geils teal Joan of Arc
Sierra Pictures RKO costumes by Dorothy
chickens and Kerensky Dorothy chickens
and karinski for John aha
thank you very much Elizabeth Taylor